và quy định đề được hợp bồng, thi sinh phải lào sinh giỏi của ra được tuyển thằng,
phọc có tổ hợp sẽ tuyển gồm hai môn bán và hai môn trong số vật lý,
phọ học, sinh học, tiền anh đặt từ 2,5% đẹp cho lên.
Đông thời năm trong tốt bà miệf tình trăm thi sinh có điểm,
có nhất cả nước của tổ hợp sẽ tuyển.
Mất điểm tốt bà miệf tình trăm sẽ được bộ giả rút của đào tạo,
công bố hàng năm trên cơ sở, vứa liệu điểm thì tuyển sọ phụ thông.
Nghe định một bài chiến quy định chính xác hợp bồng,
giành trong người học các ngành khoảng cơ bàn kỹ thuật thành chốt
và công nghệ trên lực ál dụng trải bố một tháng chiến năm hai nghĩ tù trong hai môn sảo.
Mất học bồng đối với chiến độ đại học ra được từ 3 phy bà y đến năm,
phy nắm trở đầu mối tháng, tuyển ngành học và chưa chỉ đầu tạo.
Theo thống kê của bộ giả dụng của đầu tạo năm hai nghĩ tù trong hai môn sảo,
có gần 3 trong 3 miếm môn nghiệm bệf trong thi sinh đang ký sát tuyển
và một trăm mùi một ngày thuật dét được hưởng chính xác hợp bồng,
trong hiểu định một bài chiến, chiến gần 3 miếm tà tuần chăm tổng số thi sinh đang ký sát tuyển đại học năm nay.